glenn is in rapid city south dakota hi
glenn how are you
hi i'm good dave thanks you guys taking
the call and thank you for your ministry
thank you um yeah i wanted to tell you
guys first thank you so much my wife and
i are 100 on board and baby step two
um in the first 59 days we paid off uh
15 000
and yesterday i paid off another 22 000
by paying off my
getting rid of my truck wow that a boy
you are getting it man yeah i just found
out that my hooptie has heated mirrors
i'm sitting in it right now
heated mirrors that is by definition not
a hooptie glenn
i didn't realize it spent 3 500 bucks on
it
that's high class that's high class
south dakota driving right now
right um well i'm a small business owner
uh
heating and chlorine electrical
contractor um and the problem i have
with budgeting i
i can't i'm having a tough time with you
because i never know what goes on the
top line
i i can't plan far enough ahead because
i never know from day to day
i do all service work and so it just it
changes so much and i just
can't get my head around it um
okay let's stop let's stop uh talking
about it as a personal budget for a
minute and let's just talk about it as a
business
how long have you been doing the
business six years
okay so uh
you do service work on heating and air
yeah and electrical too yes okay the
people that i know in the business tell
me that the first
cold snap is a big time because people
turn their heat on for that been off all
summer and they turn it on it doesn't
work
and the first and the first warm day
or warm week they turn their ac on it
doesn't work
so those are usually two big months am i
right
you're right you're absolutely right
okay so we can start to predict some
things
you a you have seasonality and b you
have six years of records
and so what i would do is say i'm going
to look at if you're if you're coming up
on march
i'm going to look at my last three
marches
and see what the pattern is and they
ought to inform me as to what this march
looks like
so let me give you an example uh
what what would be a normal month for
you in top line
just any pick a month give me a number
50 000 you do 50 000 a month
in gross sales and it's just me
okay i'm in the wrong business glenn all
right so
50 000 a month top in gross sales okay
so if you looked at last march and it
was 40
000 and then march before that and it
was 30
000 and the march before that and it was
25 000 you would see a growth
trend year over year
same month last year not last month
same month last year so we're seeing a
25 to a 30 to a 40 to a 50
trend all in the last three or four
marches
which tells me if i'm coming up on this
march i might be looking at 60.
you see how i did that yeah i do now
that's not
accurate because we don't know for sure
but we're forecasting based on history
same month last year same month
last several years gives me a trend line
that i can use now if you made 50 every
single march
for the last three marches then we could
probably predict
50 not 60.
yes okay because the trend line is flat
but we still have some old data to use
to forecast with and predict with
and so now could you do 52 yeah
could you do 45 yeah the likelihood of
you doing 30
is almost zero as long as you work every
day
right and the likelihood of you doing 90
is almost zero
true you're going to be some range plus
or minus
off of that trend line from the last
several years same
month last year so that's how you do
business
forecasting on your top line now your
bottom line is going to be a function of
your top line because you probably run a
pretty standard margin on that 50.
you probably know every time i make 50
000 i net x
and you're just going to have that x to
work with that's what you're going to
take home and use
but you're not going to vary unless
something happens
okay now something could happen you
could hire a guy
and that would increase that's a change
in those
over those trend lines but you just say
okay what's my trend line
and what's different this year well i
mean pandemic could be different
that could be that could be what's
different off the trend line so i really
can't predict the
trend line to be that way i'm probably
gonna i'm gonna predict it to be less
or more if you're in a plexiglass
business you predict more
[Laughter]
you know the bleach business the toilet
paper business you predict more
should have gone into plexiglas i should
have should have done that early in my
life but yeah
so that's that's how you do your
predictions there you you
same month last year and you can look at
last month
and that's somewhat of a prediction but
it could be
that you know we've got businesses here
inside of ramsey
that uh like ed solutions
our high school curriculum a lot of the
decisions are made in april
for the whole year and so we have this
huge
mountaintop experience on our p l's
on the gross revenues april april's the
month that's when the heart that's when
the crop comes in right you're a farmer
when you're gonna harvest your crop
right and you know other than that
you're planting and making nothing right
and you're waiting on the fall crop to
come in then you're gonna you know
you're gonna pull the cotton you're
gonna pull the
corn you're gonna pull the soybeans
whatever it is right and you're gonna
you know you know when that's coming we
know we're gonna take that to market we
don't know exactly what it's gonna yield
but we know it's not gonna happen in
this month we know it's gonna happen in
that month
so several callers today across all the
shows today dave have
been a small business owner i'm a
salesman and there's this
this common theme of it's hard for me to
predict
i can't i don't know how to how to guess
i'm concerned just as an outside guy
that there's
there's people running businesses
without keeping any sort of
tracking data without asking themselves
what are year over year
do i know what i'm making in this month
what what did i make last year in this
month how can i make more
how do we help folks pay better
attention to their data
entree leadership yeah go go start
listing the entrepreneurship podcast get
online and join the
entre leadership elite and we'll teach
you how to run your business
because most small businesses fail
because they don't do what we're talking
about
they don't predict they don't do any
budgeting they all they do is look at
their p l they drive the car looking
only at the rearview mirror what
happened a year ago not what's going to
happen next year
it's almost like halfway getting
christmas shows up every year on the
same day right
yeah christmas this year who knew it was
gonna be in december